okay i have to record this video because
for some reason when i recorded my well
ironically enough when i recorded the
cam studio
tutorial it came out in crap quality
so i just want to show you that it does
work in good quality just click on the
hq link at the bottom of the screen
um
yeah i don't know why i did that i i did
something different in it with windows
movie maker which is
just
just not good in general yes i
i played it
it's over here
it's playing
and it's it's high quality here and then
i went to uh what i do i want to publish
it
i want to publish the move so i dragged
it
and all of a sudden it's crap
i
it's good over here though so i hit
publish movie
next
and movie cool
then i said
make it 720p
and apparently that ruined it i guess
it's because it stretched it out from
what i'm recording now
to what i
deleted by 720 so that didn't work too
well so i would not recommend
uh just
windows movie maker is not good sorry
just
download a different freeware program
maybe i'll i'll do another
i'll do another one somewhere that's
better than windows movie maker so i
just want to show you that you can
record cam studio
in decent quality
and get uh 15 10 15 frames a second
which is perfectly suitable for watching
youtube videos
so
i just wanted to show you guys that so
yeah thanks for
watching
hopefully
all the rest of my videos will come out
in quality this good thanks
you